[Music]
I think the dangerous thing
you know that people were pointing out
with influencer boxing is people started
digging up like moments where
Jake was hitting people with elbows like
Alex Wassabi was like missing and like
he was Landing elbows on deji and so
it's like dangerous
that that's what I think is the biggest
thing here is it's great that these guys
want to get in there and put their names
on the line and this and that but uh
you know it there's something to be said
about like you're new to it you're not
very accurate you're getting in there
you're kind of swinging wild there's
this guy uh uh let me get his name right
hold on let me look it up Richard colon
and this is a very extreme case this is
a guy who in a fight over the course of
a fight was hit in the back of the head
many times and the ref didn't look out
for him
and uh now he like like went into a coma
and he's like
severely not what he used to be and
that's a more extreme case and that's
not what was going on with with deji in
this case you know I don't want to
equate the two but
I do think there is something to be said
about influencer boxing and that they
are not seasoned
veteran boxers like
even if when you're coming up as a boxer
as a kid and you're like training in a
gym and I'll shut the [__] up about this
in a second but
I think when you're doing that there's a
coach telling you like hey you have to
be able to hit the target here and you
have to be able to put your hands here
if you hit someone on the back of the
head in a fight you're going to get
disqualified for that you know what I
mean like those kind of like Rules of
Engagement that are being worked through
and and conditioned with each of these
people and when you're kind of putting
on your own promotions and they're you
know they're not like
uh
uh it it doesn't have sort of like years
and years of
I don't know like veteran coaching and
establishment like automatically there
you know it's not like these these guys
are going in there and they're doing
exhibition matches under like the Golden
Gloves it's like it's like two guys on
YouTube are like yeah man I'll fight you
no matter what
and then it's like uh okay
who knows who knows if someone gets in
there and like lands a [__] bomb and
it just so happens one of these guys is
like I don't know
some [__] like bone deficiency in the
back of their head and then they land
the right one and then now we got some
[__] dude in a wheelchair because
you know I don't know we should do the
first influencer bare knuckle fight ah
bro
bkfc i k i bkfc influencer boxing bare
knuckle yeah
dude let's volunteer ourselves and we
only punch each other in the back of the
head yes let me take turns your knuckle
then we complain if either of us hits
each other in the front of the face
yeah that was the front of the head what
the [__] yeah exactly look it I from
this clip you can clearly see him
punching me in the face
when it should have been in the back of
the head
dude
yeah I don't know man sorry I went on a
really long tangent there
um
the point you were making with
influencer boxing is like how can you
give a [__] because it's it's just a lot
now yeah I just feel like it's totally
saturated now
yeah I think
that's why I'm like surprised that
people were so many people were there
and I mean I know he has like a [__]
ton of fans but
it's just you can build up these fights
so many times before it's like okay this
is clearly just simply for pay-per-view
buys you know what this is man this is
the iteration I mean this is just this
is obvious but this is the
just the obvious evolution of all the
petty like YouTube beefs that used to
happen 10 years ago yeah
you know when guys would make they went
from making music videos about each
other to actually punching each other
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
white tweet that was like what's the
wildest moment in music or something and
they like linked the rice gum song
it's every night sis just like remember
when yeah
yeah
damn that is a crazy moment crazy moment
crazy moment man it's weird how all
these uh how all these just all this
[__] is growing up you know like this
track's like aren't a thing anymore
then they haven't been you're you're
about ricegum's [__] baby rest in
peace man
so sad yeah
genuinely that [__] is awful man
yeah I mean it's just [__] horrible
yeah dude
um
it's weird you know we're in this we're
in this weird pocket where like
all these dudes are like are kind of
grown up and the content's kind of gone
a strange way I feel
yeah
you know I don't know man
like it it was corny but whatever you
know they're making you know diss
records about each other it's like
that's all right
now they're socking each other in the
face
which is like fine you know go to war I
guess but
yeah
is it worth it I don't know
I just think like
is do does one of these kids get CTE who
knows man
yeah
it's uh yeah whatever you know I'm this
is I have no room to talk you know I
[__] I love it I love MMA and
watching these guys get beat up every
week too so I guess it's no different
but
yeah it is it is crazy how long the
boxing thing has last lasted because
when was covered like three years ago
technically like lockdown lockdown yeah
they've kept us up for three years man
is that when the first one was
I'm pretty sure oh no dude the first one
was we when we were with posts we were
watching oh yeah yeah that was forever
ago dude yeah that's like 2018. five six
years ago
they've been keeping their [__] going
for five or six years man
I mean I guess that's the beauty of
fighting is that like yeah the same
thing happens every time but you're
always kind of like pining for the
results but
like that matters because you care about
a Fighter's Legacy and his record yeah
and you want to cheer for him in the
future and see him take on better people
but in this case that's not a thing
because it's like the Legacy and the
record means [__] nothing
yeah they're not they're not it's not
their thing
yeah
so you're just watching a bunch of
exhibition fights which the same thing
happens over and over again somebody
gets punched and somebody gets knocked
out maybe or goes to the decision and
then it's like yeah
now you know uh uh all that said you
know
the
I'll say that when those guys get in
there you know just from ringside you
know
um I have to I do have to say you could
tell
the overall competition it's like it
feels like it's evolving you know as as
much as they may not be Pro [__]
boxers you know some guys are in there
really you know doing work you know
um so I thought that was kind of
interesting to see like
the dude Anthony Taylor and salt poppy
they uh
that looked like a very competent
matchup and even [__] deji and that
guy swarms they looked like that looked
like a decent you know
like
it looked like two guys that had been
working like to learn how to fight that
salt poppy was this guy
I was like oh no he fought a YouTuber no
man I love salt poppy that's my guy
yeah yeah
this guy right
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um but he you know him I think he's been
training since he's like 12 and Anthony
Taylor has legitimate like amateur
boxing experience so
they uh
they naturally look like a competent
boxing match in there
um but that dude swarms that [__] JJ
knocked out like some months ago
that guy looked much much better
than he did in his previous fight so he
I felt came a long way
in a very short amount of time
maybe these guys can't just rinse this
over and over and over again just fine I
think they can I think they can you know
I for as long as I keep finding people
with audiences that haven't done this
before like I guess this is infinitely
um
repeatable
I think it just gets questionable when
if they start trying to charge those
you know those really crazy pay-per-view
prices you know
80 bucks 90 bucks 100 bucks that's when
it's okay
this better be some [__]
entertainment you know
yeah but I think for 20 bucks
watching some YouTubers that you know
punch each other in the head it's
even even if they're not great it's
pretty undeniable entertainment it's
good conversation
you you can argue with people for at
least a few days about it you know
so
but
either way
I'll I'll say this though you know uh
All Things Considered that is a tough
ass type of entertainment to pull off